so today we're going to talk about end
games because that's your favorite being
a kid
specifically King and pawn in games now
in an end game how do you win
what's the winning method yes I agree
very good and when your pawn gets all
the way to the end and you make it a
queen what's that called pawn promotion
okay now we're going to show some easy
and some difficult endings when they're
difficult what do you do you cry when
they're easy to give the right answer
okay so this ending is very funny
because I had two students I showed this
position to they were both graded about
the same they were about the same rating
as you they were rated to up twenty to
fifty that's you're reading right now
250 okay so they were twenty to fifty
one student I said what should the
results of this position be the other
student I said white to play and mate in
how many moves either the same rating
the person who I asked to checkmate they
gave the right answer this is maton
seven he's he flee he thought about he
said seven he was right because he
figured it out the other kid we played
for a long time he said I guess this is
a draw that he wasn't right now the
reason he thought it was a draw was
black is moving his King back and forth
like this that's easy to do right and if
white plays an obvious move like King
aged six that's stalemate so that would
be a tie and if he plays King F six
that's also stalemate and King F seven
is also stalemate and King f8 is also
stalemate so I was doing this and he
couldn't find a way to win he said I
guess it's a draw what you have to do
when somebody is still
needed if you want to beat them is
unstable a.m. get rid of the stalemate
the reason it still mate is this
annoying pawn so if you make the pawn
into a queen I'll bet you that black
takes it yeah any takers if I want to
bet I'll give you five to one odds okay
so he takes by the way this is move one
right okay and now white plays here and
I'll bet you black goes here yeah let's
move to this is move to this is move
three and I'll bet you black goes here
black only had one legal move and then
white goes move four and I'll bet you
black goes here so every time there's
only one legal move then he makes a
queen which is move five and I'll bet
you black goes here and in this position
white has made in two moves although
most people can't figure it out and I
said people so I'm not talking the ones
watching on the Internet
okay this is for people right how does
white checkmate black in two moves it's
the hardest position of the day until
the next till the next one
anyone know they won at home no you
don't know either do you yes all the way
in the back did you can see you queens
III is correctamundo
we got a little Fonzarelli here Queen g3
and black has one legal move so he plays
it okay and now White has two different
checkmates the one that you see Queen
here and the one you don't see yes
what's the other one
Queen to h4 checkmate also Queen to g6
checkmate
so white wins but White has to sacrifice
one of his pawns otherwise is going to
be stalemate okay now another problem
that's really good for killing an hour
so if your chess teacher at home this is
this will be good for your financial you
know success okay although I lost the
black King so we're finished okay so
this position I showed every chess camp
and I can show it for a whole week and
the kids will wipe their brow in a vain
attempt to understand the situation
right yeah good very good
good answer okay so in this position
I'll tell you what I'm going to do I'm a
good salesman you can have white or you
can have black it could be your move or
my move
I'll leave it up to you and I'll still
be you which doesn't make any sense you
get to pick everything right so who
wants to volunteer for this study
because it's going to be embarrassing so
careful right with sam-7 over here okay
you know not have a seat do you want
white or black and you want to be your
move or my move okay so it's my move and
you're white now have you watched Wheel
of Fortune before no Wheel of Fortune
television show you heard him okay well
there's a woman named Vanna White and
and she turns the letters on the puzzle
you know what she does it's really
important she doesn't stand in front of
the puzzle yeah there you go
so he got it very good okay well they
play it for the camera but that's even
funnier okay so you said you want to be
white you want to be my move okay so
I'll go here and now it's your move okay
I guess I'll defend my pawn
mm-hmm do to do students to Duke okay
what's your turn did you win didn't he
he hates what this happens yeah the now
if you were in my last class you'd know
what to do here we're in the last class
who was in the last class what do you do
here you cry you're not yeah exactly
okay thank you having ever see ever seat
okay this positions really hard even
though it's the same position it's like
symmetrical right and you have to know
what zooms wrong is if you speak German
that how
might hurt should other parts your life
but else for chess yes did you want to
play I don't know about you you're
pretty good this may be embarrassing for
me alright come on up okay you're the
next contestant on beat the grand master
would you like to have white or black
sir it doesn't matter so I get to pick
okay and you want to be your mover mine
okay she wants to be your move and you
don't care what color I am and what's
going to happen you're going to win or
you're going to draw you're going to
lose okay he's going to win large wager
on myself okay
so well you could you don't care what
color you are okay you could be white
well you're right it doesn't matter what
call you are you worried about that so
continue okay that's the best move
that's what I did now since he's playing
well I'm going to defend if he was
really bad I would play an aggressive
move which loses but I would probably
win anyway but against him I think my
aggressive move would backfire so I will
play correctly I hate to play correctly
but the kids too good okay now he's
going to win my pawn because he's mean
but I'm ready for that he's like wait it
yeah I'm still I'm still ready for you
you can take my pawn when you want
maybe he'll never take my pawn then he's
not going to win whoa whoa no cheating
only I can cheat that's something did
you read the rules is he going to win by
never taking my pawn well this is that
we're having fun over here okay
did you read my book how to kill an hour
all right now when he takes my pawn have
a seat and don't block the camera when
he takes my pawn now I move my King in a
straight line with his called opposition
okay and then I keep doing it because
that's how I roll okay then he
eventually moves his pawn forward okay
we're going to be another hour it looks
like but he's doing everything to try to
win he's hoping I make a mistake
grandmasters make a lot of mistakes with
its King and pawn versus King and
eventually hookie pushing his bond and
now this is the key position in all of
chess there's three legal moves two of
them lose in one draws so if I play the
losing move he'll win right and then I
will get laughed at until your throat is
sore but I play the correct move and now
when he moves his can't get opposition
again hooray for me and then he goes
back hoping against hope that I'll
blunder okay see how difficult that is
okay and eventually he'll give up and
push his upon already he'll never go
buzz pushes fun maybe I'm wrong right
well it was always a draw but you played
perfect we both played perfect we're the
best do I go on the road okay we'll play
play this smooth so that you know we
don't we're not here till next week
right then here with your king yeah and
then stale me yeah you played perfect
give him a hand
yay juju I give a speech no okay you
have a seat okay so he played perfect
which is almost as good as good as
better than perfect
now the key position the key position is
this one and that position never
happened if that position happens and I
ask you who's winning you have to ask me
a question have a seat
you have to ask me whose turn it is and
whoever's turn it is they're losing
because this is the perfect position
everybody's defending their pawn
everybody's attacking the other pond so
if you move your king you lose so in
this position King here loses and King
here means that after King here you lose
because now it's black smooth however if
white takes this pawn and black plays
King here in response that's called what
I said what it was called earlier
opposition and then the King just goes
in
position right still meters later and
that was a lot of fun doing that didn't
we that was fun
okay so this is a draw but both sides
have to play well if you make a mistake
either side can lose and actually in
some chess camps I've shown this
position and I won with both sides for
an hour and you would think after
looking at it for an hour they would
figure out what I'm doing but now but
this is one of my favorite positions
okay and it gets to our key position of
this one should black play king da King
EA or King FA what do you think yeah
King da everybody agree nobody agrees
you're thinking Arby's what's going on
here yeah I want to cut it by money from
Arby's we have an agreement okay so you
should play King EA that way whichever
way white goes you're ready f6 you go
here and d6 you go here you got to be
ready
thank you move your king back and forth
like that that's pretty easy to remember
that's what I was doing we were having
fun over here okay that's King and pawn
versus King now this is one of my
favorite puzzles because there's no
answer to it is this a win for white or
a draw if both sides play perfect
how could you answer when I said there's
no answer how could they do it you have
to ask a question first what question do
you ask
yes how many looks the center of a
Tootsie Pop three yes yeah whose turn is
it if it's White's turn then black has
the opposition it's a draw notice how
black just follows Wyatt so White's not
really getting anywhere but if it's
blacks turn now black has to make a bad
move then white has the opposition so if
he goes back white goes up and if he
goes to the side we go up and we have
scored our pawn home and this is called
the opposition when the Kings are in a
straight line do you want it to be your
move or the
other persons move other person it
doesn't matter which side you are also
another rule about end games whether
you're trying to win or you're trying to
draw you want your King in front of your
pawn so in this position the black king
is in front of the pawn that means he'll
draw in this position the white king is
in front of the pawn that means he'll
win you always want your King in front
of the pawn because the pawn wants to
Queen if your Kings in front of it it's
not going to Queen if the other guy's
King is in front of it that he's going
to escort it home little Queen okay if
your King is on the sixth rank in front
of the pawn then you win it doesn't
matter whose turn it is okay but when
it's on the fifth rank or the fourth
rank or the third rank on the second
rank if it's illegal yes
ah this one yes he tried to trick me
good job you get extra credit for that
King f5 I'm going to follow you just
like last night
ticket for King up we're going backwards
that scares me a lot yeah okay anything
draws how about there now we have an
opposition sort of you get to keep going
back and your King is going to promote
for me yeah this is solid black is solid
unless you make mistakes every move then
that's risky you always keep the king in
front of the pawn and you always move
straight back and straight up okay it's
called the Paula Abdul technique
straight back and straight up
okay straight up no nothing yeah exactly
right well plate there's a critic
everywhere okay now there's exceptions
to the rules because you guys like rules
a lot when the pawn is on the side you
see how that's the side then it's always
a draw you can never win and I'm going
to show you why in this position if it's
blacks turn to move Black has to cry
because he has to play King here white
plays King here makes a queen
so this is a key position but if it's on
the side it doesn't matter whose turn it
is it's blacks turn it's stalemate if
it's whites turn its stalemate
so side pawns are bad let me show how
bad side ones are okay this one went to
jail last week that's a bad side pawn
right now you got nothing okay so I'm
going to give white five pawns is that
fair that's fair yeah is this a win for
white or is it a draw if both sides play
perfect yes it's a draw because you
can't win black does that that's hard to
do and then why play stalemate that's
not very helpful
okay so side pawns are really bad and
there's something crazy we won't wear in
this class guys too hard but if there
was a bishop here that's still a draw
not crazy well there will be a win right
but this is a draw now there's a
trickster out there whose name I won't
mention because we're being filmed Roman
Jinja all that was a mistake I didn't
mean to say his name
DZ I mean to spell it for you okay Roman
ginger Hashmi Lee used to make a bet
with people he would bet them that he
could Queen his pawn he said I could
promote my pawn I'll bet you and you're
like okay cuz you can't you can't win
this so he would get to this position he
move his King back and forth forever and
you would think you're winning the bat
that he would go here you see how the
bishops protecting the pawn and now you
would do this which is a draw right then
he would promote his pawn and say pay me
I win because he bet you he would
promote his pawn and he did he didn't
say he'd win the game he said he promote
his pawn he did promote his pawn right
you got to give it to him so he wins the
bet although he doesn't win the game so
you can't promote your pawn but the
other guy's going to take it so so
that's not good
so pawns on the side of the board or bad
pawns in the middle are good then
there's the fine
rule named after was it Ulysse says
correct no didn't after me and you know
who named it I did yay okay it's like I
don't know who what my autobiography was
probably me okay and the rule is if your
king is two squares in front of your
pawn which I would also include here in
here see how it's two squares in front
you agree you agree then you always win
unless your opponent plays King takes
pawn then you don't win so every legal
square the King is on is losing this is
losing unless you play King takes pawn
then you're all set okay then you're all
set yeah so this position is a draw if
it's White's move this positions always
wing doesn't matter whose move it is
because if it's White's move white goes
here and now it's blacks move so two
squares in front of your pawn is good
right now we're going to win something
fun okay unlike the previous examples
and it's called the outside past pawn
outside is the outside that would be the
outside of the room because you're not
in the room anymore in the middle of the
room is the inside because you're inside
the room so in chess we have something
called the outside past pawn what's the
past pawn
thank you for asking a passed pawn is a
pawn that could become a queen and no
pawn can stop it and in this position
there are two past pawns
White has a passed pawn and Black has a
past one that's White's passed pawn
that's blacks passed pawn these poems
aren't passed they're all blocking each
other past pawns are good because they
promote then you win as you pointed out
earlier you were like no passed pawns
become Queens you win well it's four
against four so you would think probably
a draw but if a grandmaster walked in
they would say no this isn't a draw one
site is winning do you know which side
is winning is it white or black
like why like not sure I asked Michael
Jackson said didn't matter
so hey strange the answer now it
actually turns out White's winning
because white has the outside past fun
that's inside past fine well the
furthest out this is the outside of the
board right so that's the furthest you
can get and still be on the board and
then this is obviously the inside of the
board so which one is outside this one
is so here's the problem that black has
white tries the Queen is pawn and blacks
like you you can't Queen that pond and
then when this pond moves up and you
take this pawn and I take your pawn
that's what's going to happen now who's
closer to those pawns on the Queen side
white or black who's closer right white
White's going to go take all those pawns
and he's going to lose guarana breath he
can't make it that far
White's going to go here and here and go
numb numb numb and and blacks King is
too far away the outside past pawn wins
of these end games now I was watching
him on the internet before you were born
which is actually true except in your
case okay not you at home the camera guy
okay and it was a game between two very
strong players and one of them is not a
cheater wink well actually they both are
okay and it's Kasparov the world
champion versus zarab as my Paresh V Lee
that's his name I wouldn't make that up
because I can't make that up that's an
awesome name that I I used to own a fish
and its name was er AB afters red has my
parties really right okay now sir AB is
his first name as my parish really is a
second name I'm one of the few players
in the world who can spell his last name
I'm very proud of that
okay now in this position I was shocked
because the game ended here and it was
white to move did white win did black
win or do they agree to withdraw and in
fact the actual results surprised me
because this was too hard
for me so I just start crying and in
fact black resigned he gave up
yeah well it's White's turn to move
actually his resignation was correct I
just couldn't figure out why but then I
figured out why because somebody told me
so white moves his King and black does
the same
unfortunately white goes first for black
anyway
and that's why black gave up because his
King felt okay King here and now after
King takes pawn King takes pawn I
thought it was a draw but white has one
move that wins and it puts black in
zugzwang where you can't move yeah so
what's the only move for white that wins
here white has eight legal moves only
one of them wins some of them lose yes
King to g5 the move that I missed if you
take either pawn I'll take the other
pawn take this blond I'll take this one
but you play King g5 it's blacks turn to
move and black doesn't want to move in
fact if it was White's move it'll be a
draw but it's blacks move and black has
to move which is unfortunate because
that's exactly where he wants his King
attacking both pawns so if he moves his
King that way white takes that pawn
uh-uh and obvious some smart alecks they
said wait a minute I'm not going to take
this part I'm going to go here rude
tricky
unfortunately white just moves his King
and when you take the pawn and he goes
back to the same position da
now the reason black resigned other than
he figured that out was that game
actually happened before and they both
knew it from like the 1940s and that's
what happened so by knowing games that
were played previously and knowing
positions they knew what the result of
this game should be but I learned
something
yeh now I know this endgame if I ever
have it again
- you're in trouble I'm over going to
have it against you I might but I would
have about 40 extra pieces also yeah so
if I ever blunder those 40 pieces that I
mean I still know this Kampong endgame
no it's not don't you guys play bug
house that I would be 50 pieces ahead
with seven bishops on the same coin an
atomic weapons of mass destruction I'm
telling the truth
Ben doesn't believe he's like no you
weren't and this was the position this
is actually very funny
and and it was in a book on King and
pawn endings and blacks going this way
right and and and the thing said white
to move it's a draw black to move it to
draw so it's a draw okay actually that's
incorrect and the reason it's incorrect
is funny it is a draw but this statement
whites and move draw blacks and move
draw is wrong who knows why that's wrong
the answer is actually really hard to
figure out because it's not really chess
related it has to do with the rules of
chess who knows the rules
you like the rules what's that it bends
like I don't understand
does Ben understand and he's higher
rated than all of you put together but
he still doesn't get it yes I've I've
I've been on him against you know yeah
well Y can go here here here here right
if it's white so move it stalemate we
agree if it's black to move it's still a
draw however that statement is wrong for
the following funny reason and the funny
reason is it's not possible that it's
black to move let's do some analysis if
it's black to move then who just moved
Wyatt
tell me what White's last move was
somebody explain it to me what did white
just do it's impossible so it has to be
White's move here
it can't be blacks move although in some
kids tournaments okay so if it's a kids
tournament all bets are off then you
know this could have been the position
and white played here you know what do I
know
okay I was at a kid's tournament in New
York once and they both had a lot of
pieces on the board well white did and
white went here and black went here and
white went here and black went here and
I was really looking forward to this
move I was like man what's going to
happen now this would be the greatest
moment of my life instead of white win
here and I was very I was depressed I
almost made the kid go here just to see
what would happen
I'd be like come on now what yeah yeah
very very suspicious and illegal play
and they said the kids in New Yorker
strong at chess I don't know okay okay
now in this position White's upon up
White's trying to Queen what is in
blacks favori here what do you like
about black what's the one thing about
black that's pretty good he can steal me
white more importantly that pawns on the
side those pawns never win so black has
a very tricky thing he can do here here
here here okay or if you want to draw
immediately you don't want to waste your
time you can attack the pawn probably
white will play h7 right and then you'll
still meet him which is funny because
black
has no pieces and he still made it white
what were the chances of that
fifty-fifty yeah okay so these positions
are always drawn now let's cheat a
little bit there we go I cheated very
little white to move what would you do
if you were white white to move what was
who raises their hand and then Dory's
your hand though yes
he raised his pencil good job what
should white do what's that
pawn 287 X gland right who says that's
the best move they ever saw what don't
you have low standards yeah okay so if
you go here and black goes here that's
probably a draw right right but if you
stop blood from going there now you're
going to make a queen then you're going
to win right
what's better winning or stalemate well
if you're playing me oh then it's still
winning again right so you want to Queen
your pawn and not have your King trapped
in the corner okay so it's very
important in a lot of positions to stop
your opponent
okay now this position let's pretend
it's white to move is this a win or a
draw it's a trick question
White's a move whites turn to move whose
turn is it white is it a win or a draw
that's impossible
ah so you give a tricky answer is trick
sir for kids
okay well White's winning because white
makes a queen pawn here pond here pawn
here easy but if white doesn't see that
and tries to block out the black king he
can't do it now if he goes here he's
stuck in front of his pawn but the side
pawns always a draw side pawns are bad
unless you Queen them then you're
looking good right okay well you might
not look good but you're playing chess
well right you know what I'm talking
about okay either way is good now in
this position
in your standard position is this a win
or a draw it doesn't matter whose turn
it is same answer
yeah draw because the Kings in front of
the pawn you can't get your King in
front of the pawn that would be cheating
these are always drawn and these are
always winning you want your king in
front of the pawn the other guy wants
his kick in front of the pawn because
that's what you want now I'll show you
some really tricky end games that
nobody's ever solved so I don't know the
answer so when you're up two pawns
usually you win when I say usually I
mean always however not this position
this is the exception that proves the
rule black to play has one move that
draws I've asked hundreds of
grandmasters and they're still crying
that's correct
King to c4 and now it's White's move if
it was black so he'd lose so he's
waiting for white to move if white goes
here he takes the pawn and then he wins
the other one and the same with this now
let's pretend black played the obvious
move King takes pawn now he loses King
here King here and White's King gets all
the way up here and after here what's
the only winning move for Wyatt possibly
called the opposition the Kings on e5
King to d5 and it's blacks turn to move
so black loses that was a pretty cool
position now there's a u.s. Women's
Champion I think she's one of three
times if she's won in four times she's
really mad right now shaking her fist at
the camera her name is Anna zoton see I
think she's one of three times can you
investigate that for me three okay and
Anna's a Tomsky told me a funny puzzle
once she said set up a position where
it's King and three pawns versus King
it's the three pawns turn to move and
it's a draw with best play and the pawns
are not doubled or tripled on different
files so I solve the
it took me about 20 minutes I figured
out the position she was talking about
very difficult problem and you could
also on the other side of the board but
and this is the answer so it's white to
move but whites losing all of his or her
pawns the key variation is king here
King takes pawn King b3 and now black
only has one move the draws that's a
strange move probably you would make it
you lose and I cry the obvious move
correct the obvious rule is to go in the
pawn but that loses what's the
opposition move king b5 is a draw the
reason this losses is very funny it's
very hard to find how to win for white
nobody's ever found it how does white
win this position it's the strangest
move ever normally in these end games
you want to make Queens right and here
we stop ourselves for making a queen so
we can make a queen later how do you
stop this pawn from moving right and
that's the winning move and then when
you take the pawn your King goes here
and you're stopping the King from
getting back and blacks like now I'm
going to get back and you're like no
you're not he's like I'm gonna get back
he's like no you're not and he's like
I'm going to go this way and they just
say okay let's see who's quicker hmm
oh and white wins right so white wins if
you try to win this pawn but if you play
King here now white doesn't have a good
move
white stuck why can't play King here for
obvious reasons and if you play pawn
here now you go in this pawn and the
white king can't go up and help so that
was a crazy hard problem that was the
hardest problem ever but if you want a
queen and you see your opponent wants to
Queen you have to try to stop them okay
if you make the obvious move just trying
to take pawns
they might Queen another pawn now one
thing I want to explain to you
is very obvious then will get less
obvious in this position blacks going to
take that pawn it's going to be a draw
but let me ask you another question if
this is here can black just take both of
the pawns and draw you have to look and
figure it out looking at me is not going
to how can black disco
yum-yum-yum-yum-yum and take all the
funds know that white canes not going to
help is it okay the reason you can't do
that is once you take this pawn this
pawn starts to become a queen
so when pawns are connected they defend
each other this one defends this one
obviously and when this takes this this
becomes a queen a much harder problem is
this one when the pawns are disconnected
don't touch the clock please
then they'll hear on the internet and
people start crying okay so in this
position blacks like I'm going to go
take all those pawns or are and White's
like what's my king over there but
actually those pawns that are
disconnected also protect each other
isn't that crazy so let's say you go
take a pawn I'm going to go take you and
then why it's like oh hi I'm going to go
here
now if you take that pawn I'm going to
Queen and you can go and take that pawn
those are illegal moves now if you go
back around to take that pawn when you
get here I'm going to go here and we'll
do the same thing again he attacks at
this point we go here those pawns also
can't be captured because white makes a
queen neither pawn can be captured so
when the pawns have one file apart you
still can't take them both if they're
here you can't take them if you're here
you can't take them ah then it depends
sometimes you can sometimes you can't
right like here if there was no King we
would attack this pawn and then after
you're here we would go here and now we
win both pawns the puns can't protect
each other anymore
although well how did you know who told
you but if the obviously of a
so if your kings helping how you're
gonna win you have a king some well I
took it off the board if you have a king
then you need to be in the 12 o'clock
class not the 1 o'clock class because
then you know does really man the 12
o'clock like the 1 o'clock class you
need a king now I'm going to tell you a
special case because I talked to some of
your parents they said you were special
unfortunately then they winked so I
don't know anyway let's say you have
doubled pawns on the same file and
you're trying to win like that I'm gonna
okay the way to win is to never move the
back pawn never never okay like the song
okay I don't get royalties for that now
so so you gotta dip to do and you're
about to still meet your opponent like
if this pawn wasn't here you would play
King here stalemate ah now you move the
pawn right when you're about to
stalemate them and they have to go here
and now you go here and you win however
what most kids do is they move both
pawns up well then you don't win if you
start moving all your pawns up and not
listening to me and leaving it back here
oh now it's a draw King here is filming
pawn here is still me but if your palm
was back here you can just go here and
win that make black move also winning
but but this position is a drop it's
White's move which is unfortunate
because white wants to win then then you
win because yay let me make a clean move
your pawn up how what do you went here
then I go here no that's true but only
for one second right the next second
would be terrible
yeah the next second would be okay pens
what he does right so you don't want to
still meet your opponent then you don't
win now this is a pretty tricky problem
okay it's white to play and you have
white what do you do okay okay but you
can brought you a bishop
a night you could get promoted like you
know assistant manager
nobody said Bishop okay because bishops
wrong well if you make a queen
hypothetically what do you think black
would do here I'll wait I'll wait why
can't you get a bishop for a knight that
you can't win that's right
alright let's make it a queen let's make
it a queen now what do you think that
Kings gonna go isn't the Queen stopping
that no so he's not going to go anywhere
that's a draw so you should promote to a
rook and then you can checkmate them or
you could not promote at all and then
promote later and make a queen either
way you'll win if you brought you a
queen it's still me when your opponent
has a king left and you have an army
don't stalemate them then you won't win